[Musique]
tout le monde le vélo vert en l'honneur
du sénateur et à ted à la maison blanche
en 62
[Musique]
la famille le mot le plus important tous
nous avons un lien éternel
[Musique]
dad
on a un problème et sied à
chappaquiddick j'ai eu un accident
on ne retrouve pas marie jo
qu'est-ce que tu apprends dès hier soir
je roulais sur la rue principale
le jury de l'opinion publique va vous
clouer au pilori on dit la vérité pour
notre version de la vérité
je veux que vous sachiez que tout a été
fait pour essayer de la sauver qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour aider sintra cadart
cache beaucoup de secrets qui peuvent
faire la différence entre culpabilité et
innocence mais que voulez dire qu'il est
possible que ce soit pas une noyade a pu
la sortir de là en 25 minutes si on
m'avait appelé
mais personne n'a été prévenu
le chemin qu'on emprunte n'est pas
toujours celui qu'on a choisie et nous
empêche de choisir le chemin qui vous
convient
[Musique]
je vais pas te laisser faire
faire quoi john autodétruire
oh mon dieu qu'est ce que j'ai fait
[Musique]
non